hey how's it going bros my name is
welcome to happy wheels it's been so
long why don't you ever play this game
pilch
I I thought
76 episodes was enough I don't I don't
know but let's check out some new levels
whoa there's a bottle run never play
that before let's check it out all right
you little son
what is that me I don't know let's go
yeah go son yes we did it oh god another
one [ __ ]
front flip oh god I'm so much like him
[ __ ] man
I love you dad I have a cabin for you at
first I really really can't poop alright
son
you ready let's do this oh yeah Oh God
you became a Wilson I'm proud of you
it's actually a pretty good ball run oh
gosh
Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] where does
his [ __ ] head go boy why did I tell
you about masturbation okay he's this
crush hey making pancakes makin bacon
pancakes but I bigger than it flip
what that's pretty cool oh god no
pancake
I love your pancake I love you like you
are my child
oh god no pancake don't leave me
how high does it fly it's really hard
can you reach 10 points are you kidding
me
oh it just goes out I got to what okay
what yeah boy no - that's not bad and we
make it to ten bro-chachos
hey come on put do it oh god oh god oh
god can we do it
I'm ever what the [ __ ] is going on
Jesus ah I don't want it I have the
sudden airship eating chicken ah
oh Jesus Christ you want some you want
some [ __ ] dick Pierce damnit
92.6% impossible challenge accepted
again bet you missed ah
Oh was that it
oh I gotta get that coins right is that
it no that was a all right well that was
pretty [ __ ] underwhelming not gonna
like ass yeah I got his ass okay dad
don't worry about it
pain is temporary death is forever ah
take a look
make a glitch legit they finally figured
it out they finally figured it out no
it's still the same
idiots falling for this [ __ ] alright
Superman versus harpoon here we go
am i Superman or their pet Bacchus not
whoa wow yeah super bad super bad God
[ __ ] please what do you think I am
Chuck suck the goo
if you bros enjoyed this video leave a
like it appreciated it's me that is
English some we're gonna finish this
video by dropping some mad life advice
don't stick potatoes in weird places
okay great I'll see you bros in the next
video thank you for watching and as
always stay awesome
alright objective killed it's me Church
is your man
damn it I missed damn it yeah I got it